[Music]  Brooklyn Beckham seemingly confirms  chloë grace moretz split with a kiss  either sweetie he's a good boy the 19  year old photographer was spotted  kissing Canadian model Lexi wood at a  tattoo parlor in Los Angeles on Saturday  the pair cuddled up together and packed  on the PDA while Brooklyn got some new  ink on his arm okay I'm not going crazy  but Chloe in Brooklyn who have been  dating on and off since 2014 have yet to  confirm they've officially parted ways  just last month the 21 year old actress  took to Instagram to wish him a happy  birthday  writing never stop smiling I love you  happy birthday Brooklyn  [Music]  [Applause]